serendipity but two days ago we received
an advance copy of the book it will
actually be published officially I think
it's going to the floor the book is
called ghosts of home and it's subtitled
as the afterlife of tournaments in
Jewish memory it's a book that is a
little bit strange but it's about a
place that that cannot be found in
Adwords
it's about a community also for only
that place has remained alive in the
words of iron like a wonderful gift and
I want those curves long after the
disappearance of things called
sure no bids the book is also a
historical account of a german-speaking
Jewish Eastern European culture that
flourished in tournaments from the mid
19th century until it was shattered and
dispersed in your
- but the book is also we tried to do it
is also a family and communal memoir
that spans three generation and it
explores as the subtitle indicates the
afterlife in history and in memory of
the City Hall Jeremy's just point out
here cherub it's under austro-hungary
was called sherman is and then was the
easternmost with a capital of the
easternmost province of the
austro-hungarian Empire the Corvina
after World War 1 1918 it was became
Romanian that was all found there an
empire dissolved the Romanians took it
over the city became journalist in the
period right before the start of World
War Two in the aftermath of World War
two the Soviet Union took it over and
became Genesee and nowadays it is part
of the Republic of Ukraine and as
chanath see so the place itself you know
like a kind of a shell of remain but the
animal has disappeared and the animal
marjorie that hasn't appeared in a very
large Jewish population I'll tell you
about that in a minute now the book is
also based their markets in terms of
sources we use a great reliance
standard sources that historians were
used in archives photographs all kinds
of shows of that sort but it's but it's
also very largely phase three trips that
we took to this place the first one in
notes in the Romanian they took it back
it was there he was a kind of August and
that's not the kind of route strip you
know that they have not been there since
they left the city at the end of World
War two 1945 now with their first return
trip and we weren't with them and
it's a trip that we cover my bathroom
you can set the pattern because what we
started really early on to film or the
video their trip and our trip and so
what we collected in that on that trip
initially since that got us going for
such an important where oral histories
on this spot the parents taking those to
the various sites of their youth and
other sites within that city and giving
us the oral accounts over that was that
became a very central way of collecting
material for us it became a kind of not
only back to the site but actual
embodiment of the of that experience
returning to someplace for many many
years and we were the co witnesses to we
went back a second time in 2000 at that
point no longer the marianas parents of
five by ourselves actually and we made a
trip in which we actually took two
people who have never been to
tournaments but we're also interested in
going there were also a family from that
area
a cousin David Kessler who his father
very important in our book because we
did a medical doctor who was sent to a
concentration camp in Transnistria and
the subsequent actually I'm working on a
memoir by his father but we went with
David Kessler and with another academic
a friend from from Israel Lawrence Hyman
who had also had a relevant subsequently
was written a book in French a very fine
book in French about about China dates
so that was our our second film and in
that sense we were they've guides now to
these two people who have never been to
this place and they tried now without
parents without any actual sort of
living survivors from from the period to
try to find the houses and the and the
sites where their families have grown up
but they have experienced by removal one
that once removed we went out deeper so
fall asleep again that whole second
experience mm we video each film
brought back material and that second
trip we also made a short journey to a
place called Transnistria I'll tell you
about that in Francisco of the area to
which hundreds of thousands of Jews
would perish he went a third time to
differences in 2006 as members let me
very briefly give you the kind of
background history and then very much
about these trips and about the oral
material now first of all if you which
we look at ceremony it was a as I said
the easternmost the capital the
easternmost comments of austro-hungary
and it had a very very large Jewish
population percentage-wise that's much
larger than Vienna percentage-wise
and Mike so many places that were ruled
by the Habsburg starting in the 18th
century the hats birds decided in a
policy of emancipation of various
minority groups in order to centralize
their authority and part of the
emancipation by granting emancipation to
minorities like Jews in return those who
were emancipated that receive rights to
be married all kinds of option rights
that accumulated over time until 1868 we
do see political rights gradual rights
to receive but in betrayal for these
rights the expectation was that the
population that received advice would
become germanized the idea was to
centralize the states by German izing
minority groups by making them enough
employ inducing them to go to school to
dress like Germans to become German in
culture as much as much as possible and
the Jews in in this place as in so many
other places in Central Europe took to
this policy doing well you have large
numbers of use that assimilate it that
picked up German and German became their
main language displacing how their
language which I've been the line
arrogance and became their main language
and the main literary language
jaren has produced some of the great the
writer is actually poets of the 20th
century German speaking poets of the
20th century with Germany speaking Jews
Paul so long the city rose Alice Lambert
came from the city during this period of
Austrian rule the city itself took on an
Austrian this is the under the Austrian
was the the main center of politics of
the city city hall at the city itself
architectural II picked up a lot of the
architecture of Vienna it prided itself
being little Jenna its streets were
named after being these streets its
architects build railroad stations
build buildings particularly the second
part of the 19th century when also
hungry was moved by by in for the front
co2 which is a period during this period
that chariots prided himself and being
little Vienna and the population
particularly the Jewish population is
drummer speaking Tatar tied himself and
some of these buildings that were built
for example this building
the main squares was called the Jewish
house for the it was a Jewish cultural
center a Jewish cultural center and
all-fours of this we do have activities
that knew the shooter clubs and other
things involved as you can see one
squares here at an opera house or a
theater in this case that were very much
again modeled after Viennese theaters
that have a synagogue because the temple
is called it a very reformed for the for
the time they called Moorish style there
the opposing building that temple notice
we call it a synagogue they had
synagogue but that was called the temple
that temple was burned when the Germans
and Romanian community
of World War two tournaments and all
that remains now is this part which is
transformed by the Ukrainians into a
movie house Titanic was playing with
people now in 1918 the Romanians took
over and when they took over tournaments
they tried to move Romanian artist leave
the population to force them to speak
Romanian to change the school's to
Romanian but for the Jewish population
the advent of Athenian was actually a
very negative
the Romanians took away many of the
rights of the Jews that had political
rights for example under Alex as
identity 68 Jews became sole political
citizens of austria-hungary
and Romanians came in she became
subjects again rather than citizens
during a period of the manian rule also
starting with 19 in the eighteen
particularly for twenties and thirties
immediately
increasingly convening fascism became
stronger and stronger
the Romanians created a
goofy very much like the Nazi Party that
was virulent began to be submitted and
some Jews were begun to to experience
direct and indirect answer
semi-professionally beginning when we
returned to churn of its after if it's
very preventable when the Russians have
run it for one year I know you know all
know that is pure set over the Second
World War but there that right before
the world war two started there was a
pact of okay there's Colin path in which
parts of Europe was divided between the
Soviet Union and the Germans and in that
division the northern bukovina arms
journalists at the capital felt early
the Soviet youth that lasted for one
year then the Germans together with
their allied the Romanians invaded the
Soviet Union and returned to tournaments
and trying to turn this with a great
rage city of the Jewish population
particular that have been internal
mention collaborating whether
Russians and they decided really almost
ahead of the German that on horn to get
rid of the Jews and first thought they
did in tournaments is that they set up
and I showed you here a ghetto this is a
totally imagine of being a totally
enclosed ghetto all through the
relegated to this ghetto and then the
policy was to ship as many Jews as
possible off to this region between the
Nestor River and the good River in the
Ukraine called Transnistria it's a
region that rather sizable but was a
region that by the time the Jews were
sent off from Monaco Covina and from
Bessarabia for this area that the region
of that region have been already emptied
of its local Jewish population you see
the original Romanian order and then the
Jewish translation of these orders you
can see here that's cool all you should
be transported across the vision yester
with
days pointless is the transport of
across the river against her and
basically dump them into this territory
without food without any resources and
they're absolutely the worst winter of
the second half of the 20th century
thousands upon thousands of stars
starvation but also from epidemics of
typhus I hear some problems of the neck
of this location
this is the region called Transnistria
BC Odessa at the bottom of the rivers
the Esther trans me Esther that's really
what Transnistria means and I thought
the other river on the other side of it
is the book River which is under German
control so this is by way of background
but we really want to talk about as a
trip to dress history that we took with
some survivors and my own family was not
deported and I think that's the the one
piece that that I wanted to add to to
Leo's introduction and that has to do
with the fact that in October when you
saw those deportation orders they came
from the central government in Bucharest
with the military leader it's a dictator
Billy of Romania and the mayor of the
czernowitz of the city
Diane Popovich was actually somebody who
had been educated at the University in
the city and had come to appreciate the
very important Jewish presence of the
city and also and decided to try to save
the Jews of the city and he actually it
was very difficult but he actually
managed to save 20,000 or 60,000 Jews to
get special permission permits for them
to remain in the city and my family was
among those we've described to
separately
the selection thought that was made and
was very very difficult and actually
then of the Jews who were deported the
transistor most of them died of hunger
typhus and exposure in the first winter
of 4142 which was in
but my family was actually saved from
deportation and so when we went in 2000
and then again
2006 to visit this region it was really
to take the trip that they have not
taken and to experience something I'd
get to know something that hadn't wanted
me really through my whole childhood
because that was the the feared place
but they have not gone to in any case
this world of tournaments as Leo
mentioned has disappeared and if it
survives at all now it's really in the
memories of the survivors who are now
child survivors pretty much or very very
old and their children and grandchildren
and it has a very lively presence on the
internet so this is the tournament FS
calm the tournament's website which and
there's a listserv and it's an
incredible resource where people who are
descendants from their survivors and
descendants from this place have kept
the memory alive and have put up as you
can see from the links and the sidebar
incredible amounts of information
translations images memoirs testimonies
about the place and photographs and the
the listserve actually goes with you
know
was established with the site and is
also an incredibly active I think I gets
25 to 30 messages per day from the
spoonful hundreds of people really
around the world and on this list serve
people at one point and it's sort of
interesting how it happens
they started exchanging recipes like
does anyone have a recipe for this dish
my mother used to make it and the recipe
started being exchanged and people said
we should make a recipe book and they
did and then somebody said why don't we
have a reunion and so they started and
it was a very strange thing like what is
a reunion of people who have really only
met on the internet pretty much so they
started discussing this and sure enough
a trip was planned for May 2006 and more
than 60 people went to tournaments
really to compare the past and the
present images that they had you know
have good seven you see that a lot of
the city actually was a journalist but
as you look at your news they went to
church in Cleveland they thought they
were going to turn two minutes exactly
so they went to the modern city in any
case here they are this is part of the
trip and what they wanted to do is what
we did experienced in 1998 we wanted to
be there with each other they wanted to
be in a group but they also wanted to be
with some of the older people who could
actually explain the place to them and
share memories and it was a very lively
gathering as you can see here the first
trips they organized talks about the
place and they organized the
memorial service at the Jewish cemetery
with some local Jewish residents who
were not survivors at that time but
we're you know more recently a
population that had come to this city
more recently from other parts of the
Soviet Union because it had already been
known as a Jewish Center so there was a
lot of kind of sharing of information
they were searching for loosely search
for documents that would certify their
parents or their own presence there they
went to get their birth people who had
left there as young children went to get
their birth certificates was that
somehow seemed to ratify that they were
from the place they went to visit
building the houses and apartments where
their family had been from day some of
them went back to the school
wanted to sit in the desk where they had
that as children and it was a very
complicated trip which we described in
the book but that's not the trip that we
will talk to you about now so you know
it's very understandable why people
would want to go undertake such a
journey what was less understandable was
the group the much smaller group that
really wanted to return to Transnistria
to go to that place and there was a
two-day bus journey that was attached to
the trip they were trips to smaller
trips to other villages where some had
had family that people could join that
have been organized but then there was
this trip to trust this chair to
experience the site of deportation and
here's where we want to read you a short
section from the book where we describe
this other trip which we joined
and
to share with you about so we say what
did this trip sigh trip the Trust is
referring to its participants in terms
of memory and history
what kind of Phil Gramm ajiz a site is a
trip to sites of deportation and trauma
what does one hope to find there much
has been written about such visits from
Memorial and anthropological
perspectives our own trip could not have
been further removed in nature from the
popular pilgrimages that many of you I'm
sure have been hearing about the
museum's memorials and tours that one
can take in Poland or other sites in
Eastern Europe mediate the power of such
a such a visit can have on survivors on
their descendants and I'm more weak a
distant retrospective witnesses our trip
on the other hand was nothing more than
an excursion to a few small villages on
the other side of Moldova between
Ukraine and Moldova and transistor days
now another Republic of Moldova and it
was a trip with practical hardships and
discomforts
the two of us really knew about because
we had already taken it in 2000 and we
also knew that the promises of knowledge
and knowledge and enlightenment had
already been betrayed for us on that
occasion and we were sure would be
betrayed for some of the people who were
taken
at the time we knew that very few traces
of the past could be found in the
villages oppresses jazz it wasn't
present difference so we had personal
motives to go in in a sense to revisit
some of the places that my family
some some more distant family members
had gone to but really mostly our
motives for joining the strip or lists
personal they we thought of ourselves as
observer witnesses rather than as
involved participants in our teaching
and writing we had begun to study return
visits to sites of trauma to wonder what
memory they hold what they might
reactivate in the survivor returned' or
in his or her descendants
trustless trees lack of an institutional
life culture of remembrance the
disappearance of its Jewish population
and the Oblivion that we had already
observed in 2000 promised to make this
visit particularly instructive we
thought that there is less memory on
site it might be more interesting to see
what would happen when survivors went
there and yet I have to say that the
observer stands we adopted in the
emotional distance that it was meant to
protect vanished in less than less than
two hours into the journey now this is
one of the very few memorials that is
does exist in Pasadena in the town
mochila futures at the entrance of the
prison all it has is I mean this is a
memorial to the mostly that survived the
victims and the rescuers and then
there's one other memorial that just has
the sights a few sights of killer
there are some sites with names that's
the only memorialization that's really
while very early in the morning of May
23rd and 2006 17 of us bus a driver and
two translators boarded of this bus our
Ukrainian to accompany bus that had we
had hired for this outing and we began
to exchanged when we began to exchange
stories we discovered that up to
seventeen four of the people were child
survivors of Transnistria one has
survived there as a teenager and one was
born immediately after his parents
repatriation to chair notes the Chernoff
C&S for two of the survivors had lost
one parent there and one had lost both
parents there the others came to trace
the deportations of fathers mothers
grandfathers cousins and other very
close relations and no one seems to know
exactly what to expect there but
everyone was apprehensive about the
feelings that the journey might activate
or provoke because of the drivers on
familiarity with the route and our lack
of a transit visa through the Republic
of Moldova he took us by way of a very
lengthy detour northwest Iran which we
encountered many bumps twists turns an
innumerable delays caused by large
trucks or by herds of cows or goats or
philosophies and at the hour of travel
half the outside temperature steadily
rose as well it was like overnight
degrees there's room for and as you can
see here repairs are being undertaken
because the air-conditioning stopped
working by late morning because the
drive fell to the generator snapped and
this week stop many times they try to
repair it it couldn't be repaired and we
soon also discovered that the onboard
toilet which is a feature that I already
had insisted on was not functioning so
the driver had to make stops along the
way so we could use the facilities in
the woods for relief and so the journey
time increased ever morning's
independence after a short lunch stop we
crossed the we came to frosted nester
river and entered what happened trust
miss get to drive to our first stop
shore garage and then to his town called
mokey left for the night
and here the scenic countryside became
overwhelmingly beautiful
we were both astounded by the rich black
soils the acres upon acres of planted
grains and oil seed buds then emblazoned
the fields in the carpet of yellow it
was hard to imagine that some of these
very same fields frozen windswept
brutally cold seemingly limitless were
such torment to the many devotees who
perished during their forced marches
through this region the incredible
contrast between the splendid scenery
and the horrors that it had witnessed 60
years ago underscored the increments her
abilities at visits the former sites of
trauma can make so palpable despite the
external beauty or perhaps because of
the incongruities in reveal passengers
on the bus became surprisingly
argumentative as the trip progressed
tensions mounted apprehensions increase
the warmer at God's Oh longer to trip
lasted the more conflict surface within
the group and these conflicts are really
what we want to share with you today by
mid afternoon we arrived at some eight
hours after our departure our bus
stopped in a shade near a tree-lined
square bounded by flowerbeds in the
small town of char garage 1941 a ghetto
demarcated by barbed wire barriers was
established for Jews in a section of
this town and some 7,000 appointees
mainly from Bessarabia
but also from the Bukovina were squeezed
into it and compelled to seek shelter
wherever they could find it yet who did
whom you see here one of our fellow
passengers had been one of them together
with her mother and father she had
survived the ghetto as a young girl but
both of her maternal grandparents died
there from typhus during the epidemic in
the
19:42 for a long time after the war she
told us her parents told her stories
about Chernobyl nostalgic stories about
their
marriage and her birth there but they
refused to talk at all about
Transnistria and yahood its own
childhood memories of this place have
been repressed as well until many years
later in Israel through an organization
for child survivors named Tom Kha she
joined a Child survivor therapy group in
which details of her own experiences
began to surface along with that of
other fellow survivors and I'm not
reading a lot more about that these
these therapy groups and that we should
talk about the mapper with they're very
interesting because it seems to me that
they feed a lot of memories to these
former children but she had did recover
a number of memories and one of the
reasons she really wanted to go back to
the place was that she hoped that it
would open up the past in new ways for
her allowing her to access some of the
scenes she had repressed in their
material palpable dimensions however
when we walked through the town that she
hardly recognized the resistance at the
remembrance did not easily fade nor was
she able to find her grandparents burial
site that she was seeking this was one
of the very important things she wanted
to find
other than the three or four gravestone
tips that still remain visible above an
inaccessible brush cupboard field at the
edge of town there was no visible trace
than the Jewish cemetery had ever
existed there it was also no evidence or
memorial indication of the mass graves
that have been dug in the early 1940s
for the numerous victims that had
perished in this town nonetheless it
could it did find something totally
unexpected in sharra
and perhaps even more consequential
it happened not long after our arrival
on the town's main square our two
translators Luda and Natasha had left us
to search for someone local who might
direct us to the side site of the old
Jewish quarters a short while later they
returned with the mayor of Chartres
guards from you see here comes back you
could have told him that she had been in
the ghetto as a child with her parents
through kisses through the translator of
course she wanted to let him know that
she and her parents had managed to stay
alive here during the due to the charity
of local Ukrainians who gave them food
or and who at one point and a great risk
to themselves protected her mother and
her during a roundup by Romanian Jean de
armes she wanted to acknowledge them
publicly because she would forever be
grateful to these kind-hearted and brave
local farm people whose name she had
probably never known the mayor looking
primarily at her was visibly moved
Sharma Road is a small town he said in
Ukranian while Natasha translator still
he continued
before the war some 40,000 Jews lived
here their persecution and suffering is
a stain on our memory I acknowledge that
suffering for which we Ukrainians also
share responsibility now only some 30
Jews remain here the absence of Jews is
a loss for which I'm truly sorry
so we it's the beautiful Jewish
synagogue which you see here of Chartres
garage have been turned into a winery
which you can see the truck as we saw
when we were taken there and if no more
than a handful of Jews remained in the
town then at least the mayor recognized
and absorbed that the historical
presence of Jews in Charleroi and
they're suffering a very understated
human exchange between him and Yehuda
it's facilitated by the translators
mediation and witnessed by our group
that other bystanders from the town did
have a reparative course that we carried
with us into the bus and into the
continuation of our journey to be sure
the mayor acknowledged the presence of
char-gar Jews before the war that Jewish
population had already been exterminated
by the exits group before the Jews who
had been deported from the Gobi no so
before they wouldn't came there was the
mayor aware of these two flavors of
Jewish suffering and regard does it
matter we don't
in Charlotte something was being
remembered on site something had been
transmitted and it was a good beginning
for our journey when we got back on the
road however the good feelings
dissipated rather quickly and conflicts
again came to the fore among the group
you can't clear that the journey was
taking longer than planned and then we
would have difficulty fitting everything
we wanted each of the two days when the
triple was being planned we had been
asked about places and fastest trip to
visit that were firstly most meaningful
to us and char burrowed mugginess
mochila photos and bear shad were
submitted to the tour company as primary
goals arthur Rindler who was one of the
group members and the child survivor
also had also wanted us to stop in hoody
a small town where his mother had
perished during their forced march
Arthur's request was certainly
reasonable too many people on the bus
why after all would they undertake such
a trip without stopping in a town that
was so significant
to a member of the group even though
doing so entailed a significant teacher
but others aboard the bus primarily some
of the other child survivors and their
spouses challenged Arthur's request
how was he so sure that his mother had
died there in that particular place one
of them passed him we got after all been
less than five years old at the time why
should his memory be trusted and why
should we have to make this detour
despite the fact that we were not
scheduled to be in the booty area until
our second day in Transnistria the
skepticism about Arthur's memory and
request was expressed impatiently as
though we had to decide right then and
there if the detour was going to be made
Arthur's burden indignation were
immediately disabled why would anyone
want to challenge his recollections for
most of his life he said he had been
haunted by flashbacks of his mother
lying next to him cold when he woke up
in the morning in a cowshed but he and
his parents had found shelter during
their time in booty his memories of this
period came back to him and black and
white he told us and he said it was like
a movie with some scenes cut out missing
I want to go back to booty he said fill
in some of those missing pieces and say
Kaddish the prayer for the death for my
mother maybe that could help me to bring
some closure I mean he was a very
interesting man if he had been a very
successful professional he had just
retired and he knew there was some part
of his life that was missing and this
trip was very very important for service
that Pisan allow them to grow
as we move forward to that to tour
particular sites within transnistria not
only Arthur but some of the other child
survivors on the bus began nervously to
draw into themselves with the shrink
physically their faces reflected an
overwhelming sense of anxiety at the
same time however the strengthened
negativity continued why did we stop for
lunch so early why were we stopping at
every cemetery somebody open when were
you going to see the cemetery and bear
show others insisted nothing was right
where we had expected solidarity and
mutual sympathy a sharing of past
experiences of feeling of community we
found wrangling competition and
bickering we were of course conscious of
the fact that a number of our travel
companions had suffered severe trauma as
young children and we were sufficiently
familiar with the literature on
childhood trauma to know about some of
its recurring manifestations during lab
a psychoanalyst was himself a child
survivor of Transnistria of the deadly
camp of Canada Piatra describes his own
heightened awareness of details from the
time the precocious remembrance of
events that seemed as he writes far
beyond the normal
for recall in a young child he also
notes discontinuities and memories of
childhood trauma indicating in his own
case and I quote these memories are like
the street islands of precocious
thinking and feel almost like the
remembrances of another child removed
yet connected to me in a complex way
when we subsequently discussed our trip
with him after our return to the United
States he told us that he never wanted
to go back to Transnistria fearing
perhaps that we have that he that we had
the occasion to witness what we had the
occasion to witness on our journey the
loss of the doubling and projection that
locates the trauma outside himself in
the persona of another child that's
insanity right as we neared the village
of booty on our second day in
Transnistria after taking a short Duty
turn off the main road to bear shop
Arthur requested that we all permit him
and his wife grete to descend the bus by
themselves and that we returned to fetch
them again a while later he had become
quiet and withdrawn as we neared booty
focusing his glance out of the window at
one point he asked the bus driver to
slow down so he
snap a photo of one of the cow sheds we
passed this is actually his photo in
booty he and he said in booty and
Akhilesh house had similar to that one
we spent our first winter in
Transnistria all these shots have only
one story but ours had two stories and
we never found one that had two stories
that need the photograph it looked a
little bit like this one but it was
different
shortly thereafter we approached the
Buster of modest bell kept houses on a
fairly recent vintage and a signpost
reading booty on a small grass covered
circular island that divided the road no
people's stores are even cars were
visible placing a kippah head covering
on his head and carrying a small prayer
book arthur got off there with greta and
he walked to the sign it was clear that
he was about to fulfill what he had set
out to do to save the mourners Kaddish
for his mother but since he had
absolutely no knowledge of where in this
village his mother's burial site was
located he stood at the entrance of
booty at the post that marked its
physical location and so we drove off
with the bus and then when we
we we saw Arthur takes some photographs
and placed a stone by the Moody sign to
mark their visit this is what the Jewish
practice of placing a stone on a grave
cipher of course there was another sect
that was all
after this Arthur slowly began to
brighten up Sudi was telling stories and
conversing and a good-humoured way on
the bus he felt lighter he told us later
in the afternoon as if some weight had
been removed from his chest he felt that
he had attained some closure on the past
later in the day a powerful image
fragment that had once meant so much to
him as a child and transnistria had
suddenly again flashed before his eyes
as he looked out of the bus window
outside now like then sunshine had
broken through overcast clouds
it would called for him a day a late
winter day the bear shot ghetto where he
had gone with his father after booty and
where they survived the Warriors under
great duress one day he told us on a
snowy tree branch illuminated by the
sun's rays he saw a beautiful red bird
instant thing he knew that this was a
sign that spring was coming and that the
war would end and that they would be
liberated and left to return home and
now again he sensed the promise of
renewal and release this time however
less physical and more psychological
not spiritual perhaps he said it was a
signal to let go and move on
in the late morning we arrived to be the
bear shock a surprisingly bustling
mid-sized town with a Central Avenue and
tree-lined sidewalks libraries will be
built they're gonna really building some
stores by the way there's one thing I
wanted to highlight for you in our own
imagination and I think the imagination
of a lot of people that have thought
about trans this grid they were taught
about it in black and white beautiful
these talented skilled was only consider
in terms of being a ghetto also a large
cluster after inquiring about the
location of the Jewish ghetto we drove a
few blocks from the corner area and we
should unpaved Road too narrow for the
bus we walked into the small area in
which many thousand Jews have been
confined
forty's in our group besides our
thoroughness father
Rita's parents and grandparents have
been interned there at that bachi of a
young girl must a woman an orphanage run
by together with Jewish communal
organization after her mother died of
typhus and her father was sent to the
German side to enforce labor
the woman was killed but you have been
particularly impatient to reach Parishad
enough to find the ghetto but even more
so she was he good to visit the Jewish
cemetery where she hoped to find some
trace of her mother's burial place even
bony within the site of one of its mass
graves the unpaved road on which were
now walked rutted from the weather and
without sidewalks
was lying the small grey brick of clay
and wood trim cottage it was conveyed in
Belarus most of these seem to mean how
to deny impoverished Ukrainians Roma
who's a confident that helps where
almost all the houses knew past where
the state of disrepair the broken window
panes rain gutters and stairs though
think rusty the roof panels feel pain
feeling pain collapsed walls and
ceilings the small yards were covered
with overgrown grasses and all the
bushes or fallen branches the bear said
Jewish ghetto consistent approximately
12 narrow roads like the one we were on
and two wider Main streets in the autumn
of 1941 not long after the devil's
creation that have been the destination
of more than 25,000 reported TVs from
Jerry's journalists and surrounding
villages were forced to find some space
within it a virtually impossible ordeal
in the ensuing harsh winter month amidst
the temperatures in the region occasion
influenced the minus 40 degrees
centigrade and the typhus epidemic reads
many thousands died in their bodies
unable to be buried because of the
frozen ground and a lack of sufficiently
health workers remain pile than the snow
for weeks before they could be taken
away eight months later in May 1942 only
some ten thousands of devotees remained
skittle this is very very similar
Harvard set but it is not our house
because our house was right near the
entrance of the mini square exactly like
this one
it had spots going on from the door the
windows there were just like the one
we're in those here on this one but this
cannot be it Arthur's comment was
indicative of our visit the fair shot
nothing we found correspondence about
people in our group were actually
searching for and yet deep sense
memories were actively - fermenting we
heard that there was a birthday at
Museum that was closed on Tuesdays and
the synagogue we visited as a group and
that was opened for us by the ancient
looking hunched over man without a
clothing who collected for us who
collected sadaqa which is charity one of
the last year's alive there was the most
desolate place yet the beautiful but
neglected whitewashed building had no
doubt been imposing his calling its way
over the dark and damp interior had long
since ceased serving his former function
but layers a memory that at home
the most participants in our group the
cemetery promised to offer what the skin
of a sense of closure repairs in the
former ghetto surrounded by a
whitewashed wall funded by a vessel
decorative black wrought iron date and
two large stars and David it was outside
of the town about a mile from the
general area we had read about the
cemetery and Ruth Gold's memoir and who
passively stood out in our memory
the first about sneaking off with a
group of other orphans from that same
orphanage in the spring of 1943 though
the function was to find the resting
place of their parents and other
relatives and the second relating of a
brief return visit to this place in 1988
the calling of 1943 search was gold
though
unquote trembling with fear I looked
around but there wasn't a single tsiyon
team to get the last resting place of a
thousand victims with perished during
the devastating winter of 4142 walking
deeper into the cemetery I noticed some
fresh graves with various sizable known
markers
suddenly I made a grisly discovery
SCOTUS got the whole area will entire on
buried skeletons and individual bones
even bones had covered the soil like
shelves on a beach I searched for a mass
grave was futile
there were only bones and more bones a
phantasmal nightmarish vision
momentarily it occurred to me that among
these goals might also be those of my
family
late in 1943 however if romanian
authorities committed to as in
translates to do see some financial
health of elephants with escaped
deportation the percent Jewish communal
organization decided to use some of
these funds to build a monument in a
cemetery to memorialize local victims
buried in mass graves amazingly that
monument was quickly erected a
five-sided prison topped by a Star of
David besides a marble clacks or the
names of many
girl victims and a Hebrew inscription by
rabbi barrel yes sir on Thursday with
called visited the cemetery 1988 no
erection is greatly disappointed the
monument was nowhere to be found in 1988
whose goal cannot find any remaining
traces whether in either exports between
now the time many of us in this group
came together in the rear part of the
cemetery you all but especially the
child survivors in the group experience
stirred up emotionally that what we had
seen in the old birdshot ghetto in here
we were stirred up especially by the
absence of a visible mass grave or
memorial that would commemorate the
death of relatives of each of us have
come to honor they collect a small
stones there was no place to put them
without discussing any human we all
search together winding our way across
sunken and a mark graves towards a
clearing where a number of great stones
from the 1940s and newer monuments of
inscribed maids could be see it
correspondent neither to the
descriptions of the 1943 monument well
the old weathered one with gold that
found it was larger square seemingly
event to the pipe Nissan international
organization
we released located read some of the
inscriptions and then most of us moved
away to make space without yet we stood
by its silent Xterra husband and Sheen
anyways found that she was looking for
she never said and inside she never
communicated the sense of closure just
unending sadness of desolation she's
doing
so we want to end with some thoughts
about memory in place heat our journey
with child survivors towards places most
associated with their personal traumatic
past we witnessed the loss of the
protective shield invoked by Dori loud
that enables survivors to live with
their trauma we witnessed a regression
into a childhood state that became
visible in their bodily effect and
evident to their verbal arguments in
their reenactment of competitive and
aggressive behaviors that maybe some of
them needn't may have needed to manifest
decades ago as young children struggling
for subsistence in the realm of extremes
information and as they're cool
witnesses at the very places where they
were traumatized as children we found
ourselves drawn into the depths of their
effect as well into what we might think
of as a loss without memory and without
history what an effect of place bring to
the act of memory and to traumatic
recall does it contain history her
memory
not
leaving their shot
we're in the process of leaving across
this draft when we left we were on the
bus everybody was totally exhausted
parched was still very hot and one of
the participants of the trip a doctor
who was the husband of glare on came I
know it also come there and sort of for
research purposes like we did but we
were all very drawn into it decided to
ask people I was up gonna be a very long
trip back maybe eight hours it was
already dark decided to ask people to
share some impressions of pickup and the
thing that all thought so much we post
thought this was a terrible idea
by sure and it was actually mostly
happening in Hebrew because most of the
survivors who have come on the trip
we're currently living in Israel so we
were actually don't speak Hebrew but two
are off Damon who was translating it for
me into French and we taped it and then
got these the transcript translated into
English for us so but even though we
didn't understand all the words that
people were saying as it was happening
we understood a lot about what
trying to say so we want to end this
talk by just quoting two statements that
people have made one was by a woman
named Miriam who had been incredibly
ornery during the whole trip and it was
never clear why she was in such a bad
mood she said she got up and she said I
did not know what to expect I was very
very small when I was here I don't like
opening my wounds but today I did I'd
pick my scabs I am in shock I don't know
how this trip will affect me
I am strong I didn't sink into
depression I have enjoyed life all these
years I want to say something that was
shocking
my bladder betrayed me twice on this
trip I'm not sure if this is due to the
shock or to my age but I remember the
first moment we came back from this pit
meaning when they were repatriated when
they were liberated the same thing
happened I tried to hide it them but now
I'm not ashamed it's what happened
and she then she said she had lost her
I hope to come back from this trip with
my sanity and with the ability to laugh
and be happy again but I don't know what
this will do for me in the future all I
want is to transmit it to my trainee how
I will do that I don't yet know and the
second statement is from
now man named Danny alone Ellen Brogan
who was actually both the second and
third generation his grandfather had
been deported to Transnistria and his
grandfather Israel was too old to take
the trip so Danny and his father took
the trip so his father was the
second-generation Danny was the third
generation and he was a doctor he's a
doctor in Israel and very very active
he said Transnistria was always a
synonym of hell for me so when we
started the ride yesterday I felt that
everything around me the Ukrainian
villages the landscape I saw was
irrelevant today I feel a big change in
me something momentous moved inside me
on this trip I felt like I could connect
to the stories I had heard throughout my
life I called my grandfather for mochila
on my cell phone I wanted him to hear
the sounds by the river he had crossed
in such misery decades ago I wanted to
let him hear directly from this spot and
despite it all we have survived it and I
called my grandmother's sister from the
former ghetto in their shop she was so
excited to hear my voice and she said
Danny when are you coming home I said
tomorrow I could tell her I'd be back
tomorrow
I'm not taking this return for granted
and I know I come back from this trip a
more complete person